okay so it's the holiday season rush and
there's a ton of stuff coming out let's
break it down for you MARY POPPINS
returns Aquaman bumblebee second act
welcome to Marwin Holmes and Watson and
vice hoo
that is your weekend ticket
[Music]
MARY POPPINS returns is already in
theaters and as the sequel to the
original now with Emily Blunt as Mary
Poppins and lin-manuel Miranda as Jack
this movie is for you if you enjoyed the
original you're looking for a
family-friendly classic with a new spin
or Emily Blunt Plus flying umbrella
equals favorite Emily Blunt okay like
Aquaman hits theaters this weekend with
Jason Momoa as a live-action portrayal
of the classic DC superhero this movie
is for you if you like DC comic book
heroes you're a fan of really any
superhero movie or like me you have abs
like Jason Momoa also in theaters this
weekend bumblebee the spin-off movie of
the Transformers franchise featuring the
back by popular demand autobot bumblebee
starring John Cena and Hailee Steinfeld
from now on only person you can show
yourself around is me okay this movie is
for you if you're a fan of the
Transformers franchise you like science
fiction action movies or you've ever
named a car
Rebecca second act starring JLo and
meelo Ventimiglia comes out this weekend
second act follows a frustrated
four-year-old in her pursuit to reinvent
her career proving street smarts are
just as powerful as book smarts you said
you wanted to be fancy so I just like
Cinderella's your ass well I got you in
the door you got the job baby you should
[ __ ] let's go who's the chain on the
tail you're the you're the chain
this movie's for you if you like female
empowerment stories you love Jennifer
Lopez's acting chops as much as you love
her music or you've never been fooled by
the rocks of people god lastly for this
weekend welcome to Marwin hit theaters
Steve Carell stars in this Robert
Zemeckis directed drama about an assault
victim who constructs a miniature world
war two village in his yard to help him
cope and recover this movies for you if
you love dramatic Steve Carell or you
might be into a heartwarming fantasy
girl coming up next week Holmes and
Watson a comedic take on the classic
Sherlock Holmes characters with Will
Ferrell and john c reilly who's going to
take the photograph I will take it you
see it's sort of a self photograph he's
a real fan I swear I never do this hey
guys
this movie is for you if you want to see
the detective version of stepbrothers
and it will ferrell john c reilly comedy
makes you LOL or if you want to get out
of your homes and see what's in theaters
also out next wednesday vice a
biographical drama d about Dick Cheney's
plot to become the most powerful VP ever
yeah right
starring Christian Bale Amy Adams Steve
Carell Sam Rockwell Alison Pill and
Jesse Plemons this movies for you if you
love historical based stories you think
really convincing makeup is super cool
or you're addicted to movie candy and
sour patch kids or your vice we did it
everyone that is your weekend ticket
lowdown on what's in theaters for the
holiday break well you see happy
holidays and check back next week for
some 2019 goodies
[Music]
[Music]